Samantha B gets herself into hot water
Roseanne begs for clemency enjoy read
somehow keeps on keepin on I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
oh I have so many thoughts today so many
things to talk about but first I want to
say thanks to our sponsors over at Linc
ok let's be straight this week I need a
drink I'm gonna be honest with you I
need a drink this week and that's why
wink exists if you need a drink and not
only if you need a drink but if you just
need a great bottle of wine to go with
your dinner this is what link is for
you're going over to somebody's house
you don't know a bottle of wine from
bottle of ketchup and so you need
somebody to recommend a good bottle of
wine for you so you don't look like an
ignoramus well that's what wink is for
wink wine experts selected wines match
to your taste personalized for you
shipped right to your door and starting
at just 13 dollars a bottle there's
nothing like coming home to a box of
delicious wink wine selected just for
you it is the best day of your month all
you have to do is fill out Winx palate
profile quiz you answer simple questions
that your average store clerk wouldn't
ask or translate into a recommendation
like how do you take your coffee and how
do you feel about blueberries and then
wink sends wines curated to your taste
the more wines you rate the more
personalized your monthly selections
like Netflix for wines essentially each
month there are new delicious wines like
the insanely popular summer water rose a
no membership fees you can skip any
month you can cancel anytime and
shipping is covered if you don't like a
bottle they send you they'll replace it
with a bottle that you do like discover
great wine today go to try wink comm
slash BAM that's t ry winc comm slash
ben and you get 20 bucks off your first
shipment that's tri wink comm slash Ben
for $20 off your first shipment tri wink
with the c-calm slash pen use that slash
better let them know that we say alright
so Samantha B yesterday of course was
the big news because Samantha be called
Ivanka Trump a feckless c-word why
because a Monica Trump had committed the
grave sin of having the gall to
photograph herself with her child over
Memorial Day weekend why you ask would
this make her a feckless c-word well
because apparently at the border illegal
immigrant parents are being separated
from their children what does that have
to do with Ivanka Trump you asked
nothing the answer is nothing but
Samantha bee decided this made of Anka
Trump a feckless award and that she
should instead dress sexy for her dad
because her dad wants to have sex with
her according to Samantha P and then she
should stump for Samantha B's preferred
immigration policy well all of this
broke and the write predictably and
correctly
went nuts they said this is insane why
would you go after Ivanka Trump this way
we just had a controversy in which
Roseanne Barr lost her show for using a
racist slur against Valerie Jarrett and
her show actually had ratings unlike
Samantha B's show where seven people
watch it including Samantha B's
immediate
and yet Samantha B still gets to remain
on air now I'm not calling for Samantha
B to be fired because frankly I think
that her viewers got exactly what they
were looking for I think TBS hired her
knowing full well what they were getting
I think the Roseann situation is just a
little bit different in the sense that
when Roseanne's creators decided to put
her on the air they were not fully
expecting that she was going to do this
and it sort of undercuts the integrity
of their products Samantha B didn't
undercut the integrity of her products
this is her product her product is being
a vile terrible person who says vile
terrible things about people who she
disagrees with right that is her product
so I don't see why she should be thrown
off her air for promoting her product I
also don't see why samantha bee should
apologize because her apology is gonna
be fake anyway okay so she did apologize
yesterday she put out a statement saying
that she crossed a line right her
original apology is just ridiculous she
says I would like to sincerely apologize
to Ivanka Trump and to my viewers for
using an expletive on my show to
describe her last night it was
inappropriate and inexcusable I crossed
a line and I deeply regretted okay do
you really believe that Samantha be
deeply regrets it or is that or is it
that advertisers were starting to drop
out of her show I don't think she deeply
regrets it I think that's a bunch of
horse poopoo I don't think that's
correct at all and then CBS put out its
own apology quote Samantha P has taken
the right action in apologizing for the
violin an appropriate language used
about Ivanka Trump last night those
words should not have been aired it was
our mistake to and we regret it well
damn right it's your mistake Samantha be
unlike Roseanne who's just tweeting out
crazy stuff because it was late at night
and Roseanne's a crazy person who takes
ambien okay I actually believe her
ambien story in the sense that Roseanne
is actually a crazy person an ambien
makes crazier crazy people crazier
it makes sane people a little bit
crazier doesn't embraces but if you're a
little racist can make it more racist
presumably but in any case TBS's
statement that they are responsible this
is correct
Samantha B's rant was scripted it was
put into the script it was filmed it was
distributed it was greenlit everybody at
every step of the way had an opportunity
to say guys this might be a little over
the top but they didn't because why
would they because this is what Samantha
bee does for a living I mean there's
nothing and how do you how do I know
that this is fake here's how I know this
is fake so it demonstrates just how tied
in Samantha bee is to the mentality of
the left you know what has happened to
Samantha bee over the last 24 hours
there was a tweet from Chris Hayes that
was just inane about Roseanne basically
saying that Roseanne
worldview represents a large segment of
the Trump base our significant segments
of the Trump base that's what he had
suggested there's no evidence to suggest
that at all that large segments of the
Trump base believe the Valerie Jarrett
looks like an ape or believe that it's
appropriate to say such things in the
first place right that's just absurd and
there's no evidence to support it
there's pretty good evidence to support
the idea that a lot of Samantha B's base
our Hillary Clinton's base and they all
believe what Samantha B just said and
it's really funny I was in a wedding for
my sister over the weekend and a person
who shall remain nameless came up to me
and was talking about politics a little
bit and at one point actually said I
wish someone would shoot Donald Trump
and I said are you insane like why would
you say that they know that's it that's
a no but he said this is like normal
conversation because this is the way a
lot of people on the left think well
this is also true for Samantha bee right
because Samantha bee how do I know that
this is also that her apology was false
and that a bunch of people defended her
because her apology was false and a
bunch of people defended her for so
first her fake apology so she sent that
apology she's so sorry then she got an
award I'm not kidding she got an award
from the television Academy for social
change right because she's a good person
who infects social change by shouting
the c-word on air about Ivanka Trump for
holding her baby
so here is what Samantha says the funny
part television Academy does the social
change award about freedom in the media
Free Press
Samantha be changing the world and they
bar the press they will generally bar
the media from essentially a free press
celebration award because Samantha B was
in a lot of hot water so it doesn't
matter her speech leaked anyway and
here's what Samantha bee said she said
quote every week I strive to show the
world as I see it unfiltered sometimes I
should probably have a filter I accept
that I take it seriously when I get it
right and I do take responsibility when
I get it wrong we spent the day
wrestling with the repercussions of one
bad word when we all should have spent
the day incensed that as a nation we are
wrenching children from their parents
and treating people legally seeking
asylum as criminals okay hmm
so you apologize but it's our fault so
it's my fault so I got offended that you
called Ivanka Trump the c-word and
that's my fault because really I should
be more worried about the children at
the border in which case it should be
okay that you called her a C word in
which case is totally fine to call our
c-word that's the logic here okay the
logic here is that Samantha B did
nothing wrong
and of course she believes she did
nothing wrong is all nonsense they're a
bunch points to make on this particular
topic first of all I want to point out a
bunch of folks on the left actually
support Samantha bees language unlike
Rosanna who found no defenders okay even
the people who are saying that you
should be left on air we're not
defending her actual comments Samantha
bee actually found defenders in the
press
she found defenders in Hollywood it's
really absurd so let's start with Joss
Whedon so Joss Whedon who's just a gross
human race is a gross person talented
director gross person quite possible
happens all the time
here's what Joss Whedon tweeted quote
Ivanka legitimized Trump by being pretty
and seeming sane well what what like why
is that why is that her problem Ivanka
legitimized Trump by being pretty and
seeming sane and libs created a kind of
sexist Rapunzel narrative that she was
trapped she's from a crime family she
married into a crime family she's a
grown-up she will do as much damage as
she can get away with Sam was too kind
so yes this happens to be a fairly
widely held opinion on the left is that
Ivanka Trump is an emissary of evil and
then Sally Field who have not heard of
for years it turns out that she doesn't
like Ivanka she really doesn't like
Ivanka she says I like Samantha me a lot
but she has flat wrong it's called
Ivanka a c-word C words are powerful
beautiful nurturing and honest okay and
so I have a few questions about this
well I mean we can start with the
question as to what makes a body part
honest that's kind of weird
I'm not sure why the body part is also
nurturing that was kind of weird as well
but in any case Sally Field defending
the actual commentary and then there's
of course CNN analyst who loved the
tweet CNN analyst named Brian kerim he
to our ha ok best tweet of the day young
lady to Sally Field who again has not
been relevant since she did basically
mrs. Doubtfire I guess she was in
Lincoln for like five minutes but she is
of course an emissary of Hollywood and
Hollywood is very much in favor of
Samantha B Kathy Griffin of course came
out and defended Samantha be no shock
there cuz Kathy Griffin is gross what's
hilarious is that the mainstream media
also defended Samantha bee so I just
have to give you some of the some of the
headlines from the media okay now
remember the headline about Roseanne
Barr is Roseanne Barr tweets racist
nonsense at Valerie Jarrett or Roseanne
Barr calls Valerie Jordan ape or
whatever the headline was but they're
all anti Roseanne Barr obviously okay
then there's the media's coverage of the
of
the of the Samantha beat comments hey
these are headlines k here's a headline
from USA Today the headline from USA
Today was Samantha B has a message for
Ivanka Trump has a message for Ivanka
Trump she called her a feckless c-word
and suggested that she should have sex
with her own father that's not really a
message so much as you know calling her
a feckless c-word I mean imagine if
they'd run a headline and said Roseanne
Barr has a message for Valerie Jarrett
things absurd this is ridiculous and
here's what the Washington Post went
with okay this is their headline why the
C word is so taboo and why some women
want to reclaim it because you see
Samantha bee actually was reclaiming the
C word for women by calling another
woman the C word
she was reclaim if feminism means
calling women you don't like the C word
just like good race relations mean
calling people you don't like the N word
you know this is what I do when I want
to have a good relations with another
Jew the first thing I do is I break out
the K word and I just use that all the
time I mean you can ask you can ask Jess
everytime I'm angry with Jess you know
just in order so that we can get close I
use the S word to describe which is
something that I do you know it's like
what in the world but this is coming
from the Washington Post the C word is
taboo but some women wants to reclaim it
by calling other women the C word
because they hate them yes you
definitely reclaimed the C word for
feminism
well done media okay and then it could
seem better here's the New York Times
headline on this thing so the New York
Times tweeted out Samantha bee dedicated
nearly seven minutes a full-frontal with
Samantha bee to the issue of migrant
children before using a crude term to
describe Ivanka Trump she's a hero don't
you see she spent minutes talking about
immigration policy before she dropped
that line I mean you couldn't say about
Roseanne Barr so Rose Empire created
many hours of wonderful entertainment
before dropping a crude term to describe
Valerie Jarrett of course you never hear
that right because the tiddy otic but
new york times this has to defend
Samantha me so this is what's hilarious
Chris Hayes spends time trying to
proclaim that people on the right
support Roseanne Barr and Trump for the
same reason which that they all think
like Roseanne Barr by Valerie Jarrett no
evidence of that but the entire left
comes out essentially in support of
Samantha bee with maybe one exception
over at CNN Brooke Baldwin
who will talk about in a second and
suddenly we're supposed to believe that
they are something different from
Samantha bee Samantha bee represents the
left far better than Roseanne Barr ever
represented the right this is not
this is not in doubt okay this is
evidentiary supported of course that is
true and the basic proof of that by the
way is that Samantha knee will not be
pulled off the air the reason that
Roseanne Barr was pulled off the air is
not just because she said something
terrible it's because the network
forecast that was going to happen is
that a bunch of people who watch the
Roseanne's show we're going to turnout
and boycott the show the same will not
happen to Samantha be her ratings will
go up after this a bunch of leftist who
love this kind of stuff will go watch
her show specifically because they feel
the same way about Ivanka Trump and
Donald Trump and Samantha bee okay so I
have a few more comments on this about
apology culture and whether people ought
to be fired for this sort of things but
first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over Equipe so you don't spend
the right amount of time brushing your
teeth I know you don't I know you're not
brushing twice a day the requisite
amount of time you're not spending two
minutes a day brushing your teeth you're
messing it up or using an old toothbrush
okay well this is what clip is for so
quip is the new electric toothbrush it
packs just the right amount of vibration
into a slimmer design and a fraction of
the cost of bulkier traditional electric
brushes and guiding pulses alert you
want to switch sides making brushing the
right amount of effortless quip also
comes with a mount and suctions right to
your mirror and on sticks to use as a
cover for hygienic travel anywhere
whether it's going in your gym bag or in
your carry-on and because the thing that
cleans your mouth star else will be
clean quip subscription plan refreshes
your brush on the dentist recommended
schedule delivering new brush heads
every three months for just five bucks
including free shipping worldwide so you
never have to think about it again and
it comes when it's supposed to replace
it's just great quip starts at just 25
dollars and if you go to get quip comm
slash Shapiro right now you'll get your
first free pill refill pack for free
with a quip electric toothbrush that's
your first refill pack free at get quip
comm slash appear oh that's GE t qu IP
comm slash apparel I have a quick to
equip toothbrush I love it use it every
night bring it with me on the road it is
a lot better than other electric
toothbrushes go to GE tqu IP comm slash
Shapiro and you get your first refill
pack for free and equip starts at just
25 bucks to check it out all right so
hey I don't want to make it sound like
everyone in the media supported Samantha
B it's just a large swath of the media
that supported Samantha B Brooke Baldwin
on CNN was the only person I could find
who gave an honest assessment of the
Samantha B nonsense so good for Brooke
Baldwin at CNN tribute to Brooke Baldwin
here's what she said doing this she is
no better than the very behavior she
criticizes in fact she becomes part of
the problem and now like most
entertainers who go political and get in
a hot way
she'll say whoa whoa whoa I'm I'm just a
comedian but the problem is it doesn't
work here
she's Samantha B she's in this position
of leadership not to mention a role
model to millions of young girls and to
women and to used that word from a woman
to another woman offensive is offensive
wrong is wrong okay good for Brooke
waddlin but she was one of the few
people who was saying this there are a
lot of people yesterday making excuses
well Donald Trump uses that kind of
language all the time Donald Trump's has
a lot of bad stuff that's true Donald
Trump does say a lot of bad stuff and
this is pure what about ISM if you're
going to ignore the fact that Samantha B
just said something vile but again this
is well within Samantha bees wheelhouse
so this raises a few questions it raises
I think three serious questions I think
first it raises the question as to
whether Samantha bee ought to be fired
and then it raised the question as to
whether Samantha bee ought to be
boycotted and third it raised the
question as to apology culture so first
should Samantha bee be fired my opinion
is probably not because they got what
they bargained for when they when they
hired Samantha bee this is exactly what
they were looking for they got what they
were looking for you know the same as I
say I'm not sure the same thing holds
true just from a business perspective on
rosanell from a morality perspective
from a decency perspective should she be
fired sure because she's gross and she
never should've been hired but I'm not
talking for a decency perspective I'm
talking from a and I would rather have a
culture that allows amantha B to go
forward and do her miserable crappy show
then have a culture that doesn't and at
the same time I don't see the corporate
rationale for firing her in quite the
same way that I do for Roseanne simply
because I don't think that the corporate
blowback is gonna be quite as great how
about boycotting Samantha B well there
there I say like if you just want to
tune out of her show go for it I mean I
would but the problem is nobody who
actually has ever watched Samantha bee
is watching her show if they're
conservative right Samantha bee is a
wild left nasty human being and so
that's not a shock at all I don't think
boycotts are liable to work and that
raises the question of apology culture
I'm gonna get to that in just one second
so we as a society have decided that we
are going to demand apologies from
everyone at any time for anything and
then we decide whether we like the
apology or not and it seems that if
you're on the left and you apologize we
accept it and if you're on the right and
you apologize we don't accept it so when
Laura Ingraham got in hot water because
she tweeted something slightly mean
about David hog the parklands are by
she said he was kind of whiny and then
she got hit with boycotts by David Hagen
company because stupid okay when all
that happened then it wasn't even hurt
getting boycott owes her advertisers
getting boycotted by the way I do think
there's a difference between primary
boycotts and secondary boycotts if you
want a boycott my show not listen to it
that's on you you want it you want to
boycott my advertisers that seems to me
that now you are going a step beyond I
felt that about Ingram I feel that about
Samantha B people should not be
boycotting her advertisers the only
reason to boycott other advertisers is
on the left is just to create a feeling
of mutually assured destruction so that
people stop doing it I don't like the
idea that advertisers are going to be
penalized for attempting to reach out to
particular audiences I think that's
silly but in any case the apology
culture exists in order to kind of shame
people into saying things they don't
believe so Laura Ingraham apologized and
the bus said no no that apology isn't
genuine Roseanne apologized and left
said this apology is not genuine now I
think that Roseanne's apology was
probably genuine because I think
Roseanne is legitimately a person who
has serious mental issues okay and I
don't say that as somebody trying to
label her from the outside
Roseanne herself has said for 30 years
she has serious mental issues this is a
person with mental problems she has said
that she is on some sort of drugs for
her mental illness the here's here's
what she tweeted out yesterday I begged
Ben Sherwood at ABC to let me apologize
and make amends I begged them not to
cancel the show I told him I was willing
to do anything and ask for help and
making things right I had work doing
publicity for them for four weeks for
traveling through bronchitis I begged
for plead but four people's jobs cuz
they're 150 people who lost their jobs
because Rose M because Rose and the show
came to an end and she continued
tweeting out she said he said what were
you thinking when he did this I said I
thought she was white she looks like my
family he scoffed and said what you've
done is egregious and unforgivable I
begged for my crews job will I ever
recover from this pain OMG and then she
continued along these lines I said I
think I'll be better tomorrow the
saddest part of all is Jayden ray on the
show whom I grew to love so much and so
she entered myself that she would ever
think I do not love her because she's
african-american it's the most god-awful
painful thing I can't let myself cave in
though and then she concluded by saying
I ended by offering everyone involved
one more apology and prayers for healing
of our divided nation tomorrow with
Shabbat says Roseanne Barr is Jewish and
she's become kind of Zionist in her
later years and I will continue to pray
that everything for everyone goes
forward and ends well for all signing
off Twitter for a while love you guys
alright so this is a person who clearly
has problems and I
I think her apology is more genuine than
Samantha beat Samantha B's is clearly
not genuine she went in front of an
audience last night and basically said
her apology was not genuine and here are
some pictures of Roseann pyre on the
phone yesterday that were taken by the
tabloids this is what Rosie I mean she's
sitting there in beat-up jeans and
essentially a a white shirt smoking a
cigarette looking Haggard looking weary
looking deeply troubled arriving with a
plastic bag around her arm sitting on a
curb making phone calls and it linked
you got to feel a little bit bad for
Roseanne Barr I mean this is a person
who has problems okay but we but we
treated as though her apology is not
genuine but Samantha bees apology is
genuine why do we do that because we
have deemed that people on the Left are
allowed to apologize and get away with
anything whereas people who support
Trump in the case of Roseanne Barr who
is not even right-wing or people like
Laura Ingraham we won't accept their
apologies because if we accept their
apologies then that would assume that we
can let them back into the realm of
thinkers whom we respect and people who
are willing to deal with I don't like
the apology culture in general if you
want to apologize apologize but the sort
of pressure to apologize and then we get
to deem whether your apology is good or
not I find to be a giant waste of time I
think it's really stupid I think some
apologies are worthwhile I've apologized
for things that I've done before and I
apologize when I feel like I ought to
apologize not because people think I
ought to apologize but unfortunately we
have a culture that suggests that we can
force people into apologies I think that
that's a waste of time also I have to
say with regard to the Roseanne thing
you know we have a culture that lives
off of crazy people we have a culture
that legitimately lives off the back of
people who are talented artists but who
very often are nuts and then we treat
them as though they're not nuts for
purposes of public relations and that's
just not the case we exploit people all
the time it's it's really kind of yucky
Hollywood's been doing it for years and
now we do it even more
we're like ABC knew what Roseanne was
when they hired Roseanne she's a person
with a history of this sort of stuff and
they hired her anyway and then they act
all shocked when she does this sort of
thing that I find a little bit bizarre
in any case now in a second I want to
discuss I wanna discuss I'm a figure on
the Left he's been able to get away with
legitimately anything like legitimately
anything but first I want to say thanks
to our sponsors over this sounds serious
oh this sounds serious is a brand new
podcast that you should be listening to
because it is hilarious it's created by
cast box it tells a fictional murder
story that involves twins cults and a
Florida what
man so here's the thing a lot of
podcasts are about true crime a lot of
podcasts are comedy this is a true crime
comedy podcast it is really really funny
this sounds serious is out right now and
you can listen to it wherever you get
your podcast so if you're looking for a
light listen over the weekend this
sounds serious is what it is the show
pokes fun at the mystery and crime
categories and you in a unique way and
it delivers big on both laughs and
narrative you're really going to enjoy
it it's a lot of fun it's a fake true
crime podcast the first two episodes are
available on May 1st they've been
available for a while here and this
sounds serious is a cast box
original go check it out right now this
sounds serious calm this sounds serious
calm each episodes about 25 minutes long
so you listen to it you're done you're
on the road that's that's how long it is
and you will be able to get through the
whole thing listen to a couple of
episodes it stars a bunch of guys who
are basically known in Canada and it was
created by a vancouver-based creative
studio but it's it's super it really is
really funny I've had I've had a listen
to it
it's called this sounds serious again
check that out any place that podcasts
are available this sounds serious
a comedy true crimes podcast I'm big fan
of both those genres so check that out
again okay so if you're on the Left you
never have to apologize for anything
Samantha bee can apologize and get away
with it not so much for Roseanne Barr
Joy Reed never even has to apologize for
being just the worst person ever so it
turns out that joy Reed who claims that
she had amnesia oh so funny everybody on
the left was was laughing at Roseanne
Barr when she said that it was ambien
they made her tweet racist things and
ambien tweeted out well it wasn't us
well joy Reid said that she literally
had amnesia which is a bad plot point
from a 1980s soap opera and she said
that was the reason that she had written
all of these pieces before talking about
why she had problems with gay people and
why should problems with Jews well
literally every day there's a new thing
coming about about the nasty stuff joy
Drita has said in the past
well here's just the latest it turns out
that joy read it turns out that joy we
put up a post in which John McCain's
head had been photoshopped onto the body
of the Virginia Tech shooter she put out
a post of that okay has she apologized
for that no no she doesn't know how it
happened it's just a mystery how could
it have happened that's crazy how did
that Wow oh I can't believe it and then
it turns out that's not restricted to
that it turns out that she also had a
post on her website in which she
parodied claims from the Iranian
government saying that that Jews should
be shipped out of Israel and back to
Europe and not joking okay this is being
reported over at the Federalist so that
is that's very exciting stuff from joy
read and she also attacked Wolf Blitzer
in the her in an old blog post for being
too nice to Jews in a post dated July
16th 2006 Rico Blitzer an AIPAC flack
after he didn't ask Israeli officials
questions that Reid didn't that Reid
liked on-air and again she had another
post in which Reid said that Malcolm
owed Ahmadinejad president Tehran was
really on to something when he suggested
that the Zionist regime of Israel should
just relocate to Europe she said God is
not a real estate broker he can't just
give you land one thousand years ago
that you can come back and claim today
which is hilarious considering the jury
backs the Palestinians claim to to this
land that they had you know supposedly
sixty years ago but apparently the UN is
a real estate broker in any case I join
Reid has said all the stuff has there
been any serious blowback no of course
not this is joy Reid Meghan McCain
responded to the rip on John McCain in
this fashion here's what she had to say
she said this is beyond disgusting and
disgraceful and of course this is right
but joy Reed still maintains her job
apparently amnesia is a good excuse if
you're on the left and fake apologies if
you're Samantha B are okay if you're on
the left but if you're on the right we
must never forgive you ever we must
maintain forever that you did something
that is execrable and awful and you can
never be given forgiveness even if you
are legitimately mentally else I think
Roseanne Barr is again I'm not saying
Roseanne Barr said something decent or
that she should have kept her show I'm
not saying either of those things I am
saying that there is a massive double
standard when it comes to media
treatment of people on the left and the
right enjoy Reid being able to maintain
a show and give commentary on Roseanne
Barr is insane
Samantha B being able to keep her show
and be seen as a is a figure of light
and Happiness on the Left is similarly
insane no wonder people on the right are
so frustrated with the culture and this
leads to the gap that I've talked about
before the right doesn't have power over
the cultural levers the right doesn't
have the power to actually get more
things on the air that are that are pro
conservative and so the right response
politically to the cultures to the
left's culture war the Left fights a
culture war they win the culture war the
Left fights back in a different way they
fight back politically and that's why
Donald Trump is president hey that was a
direct response the culture wars left
has been waging for a very long time now
meanwhile President Trump is pursuing
some really stupid policies today there
is good news for president trumping
there's bad news the good news for
President Trump is that the
economy continues to soar the economy's
doing really really well right now the
unemployment rate was was downgraded to
three point eight percent that's the
lowest unemployment rate in the United
States in half a century
the black unemployment rate is five
point nine percent which is the lowest
that it has been in half a century these
are great great numbers for the
president 223,000 jobs gained in May all
of this is really really good and Trump
was so excited about it that he broke
protocol and actually announced before
the the announcement of the jobs numbers
that the jobs numbers would be dropping
in half an hour keep an eye out wink
wink
here do you new the jobs numbers from
last night's a lot of people are saying
that's insider trading is not insider
trading when you blast it out to the
entire world obviously but in any case
and everybody assumed that the economy
was doing well anyway in any case all
that is very good so President Trump
then promptly decides that we need to
start a trade war
hey this is intensely stupid in every
possible way this is intensely intensely
stupid so so here here are the details
of Donald Trump's trade war apparently
President Trump has now decided that it
is important - it is important to use
steel and aluminum tariffs on our own
allies so before it was just against
China now he wants to use them against
the EU Mexico and Canada as well he
announced steel and aluminum tariffs 25%
for steel 10% for aluminum against the
EU Canada and Mexico
he'd exempted those countries until now
all those countries are American allies
and they are all announcing retaliatory
tariffs against the United States so
Mexico has threatened tariffs on lamps
pork fruit cheese and flat steel Canada
has announced tariffs on twelve point
eight billion dollars in US exports so
Trump's excuse for the tariffs is
national security for some reason we
have two tariffs Canadian steel because
otherwise what not clear but Trump now
apparently wants to go even further he
wants to target imported vehicles so far
the Trump administration has basically
been able to escape Trump's belief that
tariffs are an innate good but not for
long so Trump is now pushing these
tariffs which are bad for the economy
and bad policy tariffs as I've said
before these are just attacks on the
American people
whenever the government picks winners
and losers they are taxing a bunch of
people to pay for it if the government
decides to give a subsidy they have to
tax a lot of people to pay for that
subsidy when you give a tariff the
tariff is for the benefit of a
particular industry it means I have to
pay more for that product it is me
subsidizing that industry it is not
Trump subsidizing the industry it is the
American people so
sizing that industry so for example
President Trump tweeted out today he's
very angry at Justin Trudeau because
Justin Trudeau kicked back against him
here was Justin Trudeau the Prime
Minister of Canada usually wrong on
everything right he's handsome Bernie
Sanders he's usually wrong on everything
but he's not wrong when he says that the
tariffs the Trump are putting on cannon
are kinda dumb
let me be clear these tariffs are
totally unacceptable for 150 years
Canada has been the United States's most
steadfast ally these tariffs will harm
industry and workers on both sides of
the canada-us border disrupting linked
supply chains that have made North
American steel and aluminum more
competitive all around the world we have
to believe that at some point common
sense will prevail but we see no sign of
that in this action today by the US
administration ok like I've never said
this before but I agree with Justin
Trudeau ok he's not wrong when he says
that these tariffs are bad for the
economy and they're bad for the United
States economy I don't care that much
about Canada's economy I'm an American
but I do care a lot about America's
economy and the idea that you're going
to make America's economy stronger by
taxing American citizens is really
stupid President Trump should not be
pursuing this policy he should get off
of this policy immediately as fast as
possible unfortunately there's another
economic policy he's pursuing as well
that is also not smart I'm going to
explain that one in just a second first
I want to say thanks to our sponsors
over at chenyu cells so you know you got
up in the morning you look at your face
in the mirror you go aha
and one of the reason you say ah it's
not just because you're inherently ugly
I mean I don't know maybe you're a
beautiful person but virtually everybody
who wakes up in the morning got the bags
under their eyes and when you have the
bags on your eyes and ain't that great
means one of the reasons got a makeup
lady here at the studio you get the bags
under your eyes and a mitten and it's
not gonna make you look good in your
regular life well if you have those bags
under eyes this is what you need Jen you
sell for okay introducing the new Jen
you sell serum with plant stem cell
technology from chemin e Susan from New
Jersey says I've been using genuine cell
for a couple of months the puffiness
around my eyes is gone even the crow's
feet and small lines have disappeared
and they haven't come back I love your
product I use it under my eyes around my
cheekbones on my eyelids well people my
family use it and they love it my wife
loves it my mom likes it so much than
when she comes over to our house and
there's extra she grabs it with it's
instant effects you will see results in
the first
hours or you get your money back they
guarantee it for a limited time order
Jen you sell trash Japanese brand new
genuine cell eyelid lift for droopy
sagging eyelids for absolutely free
there's no reason for you to look like
Huckleberry Hound call 866 320 904 at
800 663 2904 or visit Jenny Cellcom
that's Jenny Cellcom again call now
express shipping is free 800 663 2904 or
genu Cellcom GE and you see e Elcom
jenny Cellcom go check it out ok so in a
second I'm gonna get to president
Trump's other foolish economic policies
pursuing in the middle of a big economic
boom which makes no sense but first
you're gonna have to go over to daily
wire calm because today is mailbag day
so if you want to subscribe today's the
day to do it you can get your questions
in I'm answering them alive so you can
have all of your life questions answered
right before your very eyes and you can
be edified and enlightened and leave
your best life all you have to do is
give me money all you have to do is pay
$9.99 a month and then you get into the
club and you can ask questions also if
you want the annual subscription you get
this the very greatest in tumblers the
leftist tears hot or cold tumblr do not
believe steven crowder when he says that
this gives us best that this is filled
with asbestos it is not true it is not
filled with asbestos it is filled with
nectar of the gods ambrosia it is filled
with things that will prevent you from
ever being ill the rest of you well I
can't make that claim actually
technically because that's but but maybe
maybe it's true in any case check it out
leftist here's hot or cold tumblr you
will love it and if you just wanna
listen later please go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud by the way you should go over
and should subscribe right now over
there because on Sunday we have the
fantastic Joe Rogan Joe Rogan came in to
the studio we had a nice long hour-long
interview it was a blast Joe's awesome
and you're gonna you're gonna enjoy that
one we've got the Sunday special comes
out every Sunday we have a bunch of big
guests coming up as well so check that
out we are the fastest we are the
fastest and fastest-growing and largest
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so to finish up the the bad
trumpian policy of the day president
Trump also has now suggested that they
want to make plans to order grid
operators like power grid operators to
buy electricity from struggling coal and
nuclear plants in an effort to extend
their life a move that would represent
an unprecedented intervention into US
energy markets according to a 41 page
draft memo obtained by Bloomberg and
circulated before an NSC meeting on the
subject Friday quote federal action is
necessary to stop the further premature
retirements of fuels secure generation
capacity so they're saying that for
strategic reasons we have to actually
protect our coal plants and that are
obsolete or our nuclear plants that are
obsolete this is really stupid
the reason it's really stupid is of
course it means that you are now going
to have to pay more for power okay
whenever the government decides that you
have to subsidize a particular industry
this means that you're going to have to
pay more for power now the reason this
is so dumb is because the economy is
doing great okay this is a headline from
The New York Times today quote we ran
out of words to describe how good the
job numbers are the economy is in a
sweet spot with steady growth and broad
improvement in the labor market and this
one from the Washington Post the black
unemployment rate has never been closer
to the white unemployment rate these are
great headlines for the economy why
would the President of the United States
blow those headlines in order to
redistribute that's basically what he's
talking about
he sent about redistributing from one
industry to another from certain tax
payers to other taxpayers it is a waste
of time it is a waste of money it is
counterproductive
the president should get off this
immediately you know you were a year old
enough to remember when it was anti
crony capitalism that ruled the
Republican Party when the tea party came
along so we don't like crony capitalism
we don't like corporatism we don't like
Solyndra payoffs we don't like picking
winners and losers and now apparently if
it's Trump I guess it's okay but it
ain't okay so President Trump should get
off of this right now it is that
economic policy it is an anti freedom
policy the government does not have the
capacity to tell you how to shop does
not have the capacity to tell you that
you should spend more on particular
goods and services simply because Donald
Trump wants to win votes in particular
areas of the American economy and it's
it's bad stuff it's bad stuff and it was
bad when Obama did it it would've been
bad if Hillary done it it is bad when
Trump does it as well is bad when Bush
did it too I criticized Bush at the time
when he had steel tariffs for example
okay it's mailbag times let's let's
mailbag it up so Josh says dear Ben
recently I was talking to a friend
the current state of the Middle East and
he got fed up and essentially questioned
the necessity of average Americans
needing to be constantly updated and
aware of Foreign Affairs and national
controversies arguing ignorance is bliss
what is the baseline of knowledge of
politics and current events an average
person should be aware of and what he
believed is the main reason the average
citizen should stay informed guess you
have any plans to do a public speaking
tour in the future we miss you back here
in Chicago so first of all we are doing
a couple of events in in Dallas and
Phoenix those are coming up in August
the tickets to those are selling really
fast if you want the remaining tickets
which are running out go over to Daley
wired.com slash events right now and buy
your tickets before they run out that's
coming up in August and already almost
selling out and it's you know barely
June so check that out but as far as
what is the baseline of information that
you need to be informed I mean it's up
to you you don't have to be informed
about news but if you want to know
what's coming now if you are interested
in being a good citizen I think good
citizenship meaning involvement in the
public sphere requires a baseline level
of knowledge I would say that reading
the front page of the newspaper every
day and the articles on the front page
of the newspaper every day or reading
the most trafficked articles it's daily
wire for example will give you a broad
overview listening to my show I think
will give you a broad enough overview of
the of the news of the day that you can
speak fluently about these issues
outlets and I don't think you have to
know who the president of Kazakhstan is
I don't think you have to know about the
local oil crisis in Myanmar I don't
think you have to know all of these
things but I do think that there are
certain broad narratives that have been
important over time knowing enough about
like the Israel Arab issue is important
because that crops up frequently knowing
enough about Russian foreign policy is
important because that crops up
frequently knowing enough about what the
EU is knowing basic things I think is
important and having a worldview having
the worldview that suggests for example
that Western civilization is worth
preserving and defending that
multiculturalism is is foolish and
counterproductive knowing enough to have
a worldview is really important because
politics are really just an extension of
your values so know your own values and
that very often will dictate politics
because the facts may change and the
evidence may change but your values are
rarely going to change your underlying
values are rarely going to change Joshua
says hey Ben even though mid term polls
are not nearly as devastating the
Republicans as originally anticipated
how do you think Trump reacts at the
house and/or Senate flip well his
president is there any chance he
continues to walk the conservative line
or is it far more likely we start to see
more liberal policy out of the white
house love the show okay so Josh I think
that let's say that you know is not
gonna happen let's say the Democrats
flipped the Senate
let's say they flip the house then it
all depends on what they do if they try
to impeach President Trump he will be
the most right-wing president ever the
best thing that has happened for
conservatives is that leftists have been
attacking Trump non-stop it's been great
because what it means that President
Trump looks at the left he says you guys
are jerks I'm gonna go hang out my
friends over here on the right and then
it's all the thing the right wing wants
if Chuck Schumer and Nancy Pelosi had
been smart in the first month they were
to go on to president Trump that said
listen
mr. president you are a world-changing
present you have changed the world and
you together with us we can change the
world together let's pass a bipartisan
nationalized health care bill there's at
least a 50% shot Trump would've gone for
it but instead the Democrats are stupid
they said Donald Trump is evil he's scum
he's the worst person we have ever seen
we can't work with him he's a right-wing
fanatic and Trump was like well fine go
after yourselves
bye and then he just went over to the
right and did exactly what the right
wanted him to do which is awesome so
keep going at it left really appreciate
it
Santino's says hey ben what books can
you recommend in regards to bettering
business like face-to-face communication
skills I started an internship in the
New Jersey State House soon and good
luck with that
and I am sort of an introvert so there
is so there are a couple of books that
I've recommended in the past on body
language I'm trying to remember what the
names of the books were off the top of
my head but you should study some basic
body language you can you can do that
also through YouTube videos there there
are just some good things to know about
how you reflect body language back at
people and what it is that people are
looking for when they communicate I'm
I'm trying to find out like I'm
currently searching to try and figure
out exactly what those books were that
I'd recommend it but there are a bunch
that they're a bunch of them discussing
exactly how to communicate better with
people using kind of you know facial
expressions and body language and all
this stuff it actually does matter I got
very into this for a period of time
because there was actually a show about
it you remember this they was called lie
to me now with Tim Roth there is there's
a show all about it where he was just
using micro expressions to analyze
people it lasted for like a season but
it was kind of a fun show and and so
they're they're a bunch of books that
you can check out body language books I
would recommend are good for
communication so check that out okay
Veronica's house how can we argue that
the US was built on judeo-christian
values and not merely enlightenment
principles the way you can argue that is
that the French Revolution was also
built on enlightenment principles so was
comped bureaucratic nonsense
so was Nazism so was communism these
were all built on certain enlightenment
principles and to pretend otherwise
is to be ignorant of exactly what drove
a lot of the Enlightenment and so-called
counter enlightenment jean-jacques
Rousseau considered himself a part of
the Enlightenment he was considered in
the light man thinker so it always is
frustrating to me when people say well
the Enlightenment was just John Maki
basically this is my critique of Steven
Pinker's book so Steven Pinker has a
book called enlightenment now it's 400
pages about why the enlightenment
awesome great
I love the Enlightenment I'm a fan I
like individualism I like the idea that
we have innate human rights all these
things are good but these have deeper
roots things weren't just born in 1760
right history has a longer history Hugo
Grotius was talking about human rights
back in the 16th century he was a
religious Christian and he was using
religious Christianity as a as a way of
explaining why human beings should have
inherent rights ok all of this is well
documented it is my entire new book is
actually about exactly this why it is
that we can't just say enlightenment why
we have to say enlightenment rooted in
judeo-christian principles you also have
to ask the question why is it that if
the Enlightenment was really separable
from judeo-christian principles it
didn't just happen anywhere why didn't
the Enlightenment just crop up in China
or India or South America or Africa why
did it crop up in a judeo-christian
civilization that has a 2,000 year
history of dealing with exactly these
ideas so I just I don't buy the argument
that the Enlightenment alone is enough
reason unmoored from traditional values
ends in gulags and and death camps and
religion unmoored from reason ends in in
theocracy of chronic tyranny nuns in the
Spanish Inquisition I think you need
both of them and I think they need to be
merged and I think that's what brings
about the Enlightenment is the merger of
judeo-christian values and reason that
there's a reason that the founders were
largely religious despite all the
talking about even the ones who were not
quote-unquote religious were Jesus who
believed in the power of a divine being
who created an understandable universe
and a certainty Leigha logical ability
to understand how the universe is
directed so I I just I find the argument
that the Enlightenment just sort of
floats out there on its own and
everything that's good is enlightenment
based like Pinker says and everything
that's not good we can just call counter
enlightenment I don't think that's right
I think it's a narrow read of history
that's far too convenient Daniel says
hey Ben you say you're a free speech
absolutist does that mean you would read
and listen to opinions by people you
deem to be too extreme or unethical
examples would include people like Peter
Singer no I'm Chomsky a Norman
Finkelstein thanks shabbat shalom well
I'm a free speech absolutist from a
governmental perspective I'm not a free
speech absolutist in the sense I think
all opinions are created equal or
valid right this isn't this is an
argument that I had with for example
Milo gianopolous in 2016
Milo is basically saying all opinions
should be taken seriously all opinions
we should violate every taboo I can say
whatever garbage thing I want to say and
you should back me in that because I
think that I should be able to say what
I want to say and my view was the
government should not tell you what to
say but doesn't mean your opinion ain't
garbage doesn't mean you didn't say a
garbage thing so should Peter Singer be
restricted from speaking no should know
I'm Chomsky be restricted from speaking
no by the book pieces of human debris
absolutely John says hey Ben when you
subvocal do you sub vocalize when you
read I know you say you read quickly and
I'm curious if you announce the words in
your head or just gaze over them no I I
don't subvocal eyes when I read I just
look at the words in fact when I think
about it too much and start to subvocal
eyes it's deeply irritating to me and
then I just start trying to read faster
so that I can stop the voice in my head
from going I don't like voices in my
head
so Zachary says dear Ben I someone
gearing up to start Law School but
working full time how do you stay
organized and prioritize all your
activities while still finding free time
and are able to get good sleep please
help well number one you have to know
your actual skill set and you have to
know what you're good at what you're bad
and then you have to chart out your time
you legitimately have to chart out your
time including charting out breaks so
that means you're gonna work for a
certain amount of time in the morning
and then you're going to take a break
and you're gonna enforce that break and
then you are going to come back and
you're gonna work for a certain amount
of time in the afternoon and then you're
going to enforce that break what people
usually do is they sort of drift in and
out of work where they work and then
they check Twitter for a while and they
work some more and then they go out and
then they work that's not the way that
people should be focusing virtually
every study I've ever seen says that the
way to focus is to look directly at the
work that you are doing right to look at
that work and to take that work
seriously until you are done no one is
really good at multitasking right I'm
pretty good at multitasking for somebody
multitasking but it's not nearly as good
as when I'm concentrating on a project
in fact one of the great irritants to my
wife is the fact that when I'm
concentrating on something she can be
talking directly at me and I do not even
notice that it is happening people in
the office know this is a reality right
a little bit legitimately before every
show I'm probably working on an article
and send you out or mathis or just have
to try and shout into my ear that the
shows about to begin
because I'm too busy doing whatever it
is that I'm doing you know it's a good
quality in terms of being able to work
the bad quality in terms of being
respectful to other people so I've been
working on it a little bit and failing
Alan says I agree with your position on
tariffs and trade but I have a question
don't the countries being targeted for
tariffs imposed
tariffs against the USA already why is
it wrong for Trump for firm to fight for
a balanced playing field my preference
would be for his actions to be
successful in the elimination of all
tariffs among our trading partners what
am I missing am I just you simplistic no
that's not irrelevant I mean if the idea
of trying to tariffs another country to
leverage them to lower their own tariffs
is the idea that's one thing if you're
trying to use it as a tactic to get them
to lower tariffs that's one thing if
you're using it as a tactic in order to
damage the other side just because you
think that trade is a zero-sum game or
if you're trying to use tariffs as a way
to enrich certain industries at the
expense of others in your own country
then tariffs are stupid but using
tariffs as a tactic I mean use it more
right you embargo other countries in war
so if you're trying to get them to if
you're trying to leverage them tariffs
can be used as a leverage point which is
why for example you see the EU raising
tariffs on the United States when the
United States raises tariffs on the EU
Nicholas has been my recently my
five-year-old son asked for a nerf gun
and a water gun for his upcoming
birthday well I'm a huge Second
Amendment supporter and owned a handgun
myself I'm a little hesitant to buy
these guns for him because I'm afraid of
reducing the seriousness and
responsibility of gun ownership to mere
toys and the message that could send
regarding our freedom to keep in bear
arms what say would you purchase gun
related toys for any of your children
thanks love the show yeah I purchased
nerf guns and water guns for my kids
like I see no problem with that
I grew up with nerf guns and water guns
it didn't make me any less respectful of
guns you know you first of all you know
five-year-old is is too young to be
educated about real guns in the first
place so make sure that your guns are
locked up obviously but you know when
when there's a bear there's a grave
difference by obviously and you know
this between nerf gun and water gun
which weighs nothing and has no weight
it has no heft it doesn't look dangerous
and I mean they're colorful and and fun
now and and an actual gun the one thing
I don't like actually is they're these
these guns these kind of faux guns that
are made and that look like regular guns
but are actually not that I actually
have a problem with mainly because I
think that you buy that for your kid
your kid pulls that out in a public area
it's a serious problem so you should get
guns that if you're gonna get a water
gun get a colorful water gun that
doesn't look like an actual gun
obviously Ryan says hi Ben my name is
Ryan good and I'm a first generation
American my dad was born in Cuba and
came here in 1957 he's always been a
strong supporter of the US sanctions on
Cuba I of course have been as well my
views met beginning to change on the
subject I agree with everything our
spirit animal has said about Cuba in the
UN especially about Cubans not being
free our spirit animal being nikki Haley
I just feel that maybe it might be time
to let free-trade happen between the two
countries and see what happens
what
pros and cons of not continuing the
embargo and travel restrictions well the
the pro of of dumping the embargo is
presumably that the country will get
richer and then eventually some of those
benefits will accrue to the population
the proof of this is China where poverty
has been sliced by a significant margin
thanks to opening the Chinese economy
the con is that the Chinese government
is still run by a bunch of communist
thugs so the con is that you re
enshrining that's a tater ship for a
longer period of time the Pro is that
you might be helping some of the people
who are living there the real question
is do we have any real do have any real
plan to topple the regime in Cuba if we
don't have a real plan to topple the
regime in Cuba it seems to me that there
is no reason to keep the embargo going
other than to punish the regime and
punishing the regime for 50 years has
not actually done anything to actually
topple the regime
so either topple the regime er don't
topple the regime or come up with a
better plan to topple the regime
sanctions rarely topple regimes we need
something stronger than that and I would
be fully in favor of us providing covert
aid to any rebel group in Cuba who wants
to kill the Castros and take over the
country but so long as you know so long
as they would like to replace it with
something better Justin says hey Ben
what is your opinion or view on some
modern musical and movie hits like lame
is and Phantom of the Opera as well as
even more recent popular hits like lala
land hairspray and the greatest showman
so I haven't seen greatest showmen
frankly I was not interested the preview
was so bad that I couldn't get myself to
do it although I've heard that it's
enjoyable hairspray I am NOT a fan I
find it kind of obnoxious la-la-land I
was impressed but I really liked the
director of lala land first of all right
he also did whiplash which is a better
movie lala land
I thought the songs were memorable it
makes me upset when they cast musicals
where people cannot sing or dance it
seems to me that there are lots of
people who can sing and dance and you
could cast those people instead of
casting Ryan Gosling who cannot sing or
dance or Emma Stone who cannot sing or
dance that must owns a very good actress
but her voice is extraordinarily weak
and she cannot move on-screen but I like
the people were trying I mean I
appreciate the the effort although I
didn't particularly like the ending wall
and lame is and phantes in the Opera I
didn't like on stage very much but I
actually think they're both relatively
effective movies so lame is I think is
actually more ineffective as a movie
than it is on stage on stage it's just
really long and the 30d airs dominate
and they're obnoxious and irritating but
also the scoring for the movies a lot
better one of the big problems with the
score in the original aim is is that
it's all synthesized so having a
synthesized score to represent
18 in turrets represent 19th century
France is really stupid I have a lot of
problems lemmas musical III like the
book but I think that the musical itself
there like two memorable songs in
lamia's and they're not the ones
everybody thinks so stars is a memorable
song and one day more at the end of the
first act is a memorable number and all
the other numbers I find kind of boring
but that's just my critique and if you
want to see video of me singing stars
you can actually find that on YouTube
because that was something I did one day
for no reason Jonathan says dear Ben
first off it was awesome seeing you
Yukon and being able to ask you a
question was definitely one of the
coolest moments of my life well thank
you I appreciate that we need to get you
a cooler life because you know I'm not
that cool do you think there's any hope
of overturning roe v-- wade excuse me in
the next 20 years and you think it'd be
easier to amend the Constitution to
achieve this rather than having the
court to overturn their own previous
decision yeah I think constitutional
amendment will probably be easier than a
court overturning the decision just
because right now let's say that Justice
Kennedy is replaced I think then you
would have four votes to overturn I
really really doubt that you're gonna
get Justice Roberts to overturn roe v
wade he just doesn't seem like he has
the intestinal fortitude for that sort
of thing but that said it's it's
possible I mean it's possible I suppose
so right now who would vote to overturn
right now you'd have a leader who'd vote
overturn you would have Thomas who would
vote to overturn you would have
presumably Gorsuch who would vote to
overturn and you would have whoever
replaces Kennedy who'd vote to overturn
if President Trump does it right but
again Roberts would still be the swing
vote so that would be a serious problem
on the Supreme Court I just wanna make
sure I'm getting the math correct
so yeah that's yeah but I believe that's
right so that that it would still be
there there's still not enough votes
there's not enough conservatives on the
court to actually to actually get that
done unfortunately so yeah I wish I wish
but I think the best option is probably
gonna be a constitutional amendment to
at least retract roe v wade even if you
don't believe that there should be a
constitutional amendment to ban abortion
and protect life unborn life under the
Constitution then at the very least you
can retract roe v wade and toss it back
to the states which should at least be a
step in the right direction
okay so let's do a couple of things I
like and then a couple of things I hate
and then let's get out of here so things
I like today my daughter has been very
into this when I was a kid there's this
series of CDs that came out called
classical kids they're really fun
yeah they basically educate your kids
about the lives and music of the great
composers of history the one that my
daughter is very into right now is
there's one called Vivaldi's ring of
mystery and it's this they weave this
little story about Venice and Vivaldi
who actually ran an orphanage for girls
and how he was a priest and it tells his
whole life story but in the context of
this mystery about a broken violin he's
really cute my daughter loves it and
it's a replete with the music of Ivaldi
and it tells his life story in the
middle there's another one that was very
famous called Beethoven lives upstairs
that was really really good you can
check that one out also there's a book
of it these CDs are a little bit hard to
find I wish they would we release them
but they're really excellent for kids
and if you want to educate your kids
about great composers in their lives how
there's what's you there's one on
Vivaldi I believe there's one on Bach I
know that there's there's one on Mozart
that's great the one on Mozart is they
did a children's version of The Magic
Flute it's really terrific so check it
out classical kids it's it's really cute
and I love that my daughter loves it
it's just it's really charming okay time
for a couple of quick things that I hate
okay so john bainer who apparently is
just going around becoming like a lounge
act he just goes around drinking and
smoking and then growling at people
while leaning on a piano he was you can
see I'm drinking literally in this video
right he's literally sitting there
drinking in the video while he does this
interview because that's John Boehner
man and John Boehner says there is no
Republican Party under President Trump
but I want to talk to you about what's
happened with the Republican Party there
is no Republican Party there's a Trump
party the Republican Party was kind of
taken a nap somewhere
okay that's utter nonsense obviously
that is not true President Trump does
not get everything that he wants
president Trump has largely been a good
advocate for Republican policies a
better advocate than John Boehner was I
think in many ways now I don't think
Boehner was as bad a speaker of the
house as some people think he was that
said he was certainly not a hard fighter
for Republican principles in any serious
way so this idea that the Republican
Party was hijacked by by Trump
completely it was one of my worries I
don't think that worry is fully
materialized okay one hundredth
correction I wanna make so I'm getting
tons of mail about Tommy Robinson so
Tommy Robinson I said earlier this week
on one of the shows I'd said that he was
all right or that he was or that he was
far-right or whatever it was and I'll be
honest with you I'd read some accounts
of him he had said a couple of things
that looked all
Riteish right he had said after the 7/7
bombings in in britain he had said that
basically all muslims were responsible
which is a terrible thing to say he
later apologized for it though and so I
want to give you a more rounded view of
who Tommy Robinson is from a guy I trust
Douglas Murray so Douglas Murray covers
this sort of stuff in Europe all the
time and I think there's a better take
on Tommy Robinson than the one that I
gave earlier this week and so I want to
apologize in a place that with Douglas
Marissa take so here's what Tommy here's
what Douglas Murray writes over at
National Review
Tommy Robinson is a British political
activist and citizen journalist who came
to prominence in Britain almost a decade
ago when he founded the English Defence
League the EDL was a street protest
movement in Britain whose aims could
probably best be to summarizes anti
Islamization it emerged in the town of
Luton after a group of local Islamist
bericht the homecoming parade of a local
regiment returning from service in
Afghanistan from their earliest protests
the EDL's members sought to highlight
issues including Sharia law
Islam's attitudes toward minorities and
the phenomenon that would become
euphemistically known as grooming gangs
in reality these protests often
descended into hooliganism and low-level
violence naturally helped along by
self-described anti-fascist the
authorities did everything they could to
stop the EDL and the media did
everything possible to demonize them in
a foretaste of things to come very few
people made ever any effort to
understand them and nobody paid any
price for claiming that the EDL was
simply a fascist organization and then
anybody who even tried to understand
them must be a fascist - I interviewed
Tommy Robinson five years ago after he'd
left the EDL having by his own admission
failed to keep extremist including
actual neo-nazis away from the movement
as he said then one of the problems of
everyone insisting that a particular
movement is campaigning for the
fourth-ranked is that very few people
who'd think that sounds like a great
idea will show up whatever his other
faults there is no evidence Robinson
thinks that way indeed he was once
charged with assault for head-butting a
Nazi sympathizer who wouldn't leave an
EDL protest
not many people bothered with those
details the assault got reported but not
the cause so the fact that Robinson had
head-butted a Nazi became yet more
evidence that he himself must be some
kind of Nazi and then he tells Douglas
Murray tells a bunch of stories about
the sort of stuff that Tommy Robinson
has done in March Robinson was suspended
from Twitter where he had almost half a
million followers
the social media site which merrily
allows terrorist groups like Locke
lashkar-e-taiba to keep accounts decided
the Robinson should be suspended for
tweeting out a statistic about Muslim
rape gangs that itself originated from a
Muslim from the Muslim run Quilliam
foundation and it is on this matter that
the latest episode in the Robinson drama
started and is now drawn worldwide
attention and then
we talked about earlier in the week the
fact that Robinson was arrested for even
covering a trial about grooming gangs
grooming gangs are these apparently
Muslim groups of men in Britain in
several major cities who have been
essentially creating rape gangs of
children and grooming them for rape
that's that's what the cases actually
are about so the the Robinson would not
so here's what Douglas Murray writes
about he says Robinson would not now be
in jail if he had not once again
accosted defendants in an ongoing trial
outside the courthouse he'd been told by
a judge last May not to do this and yet
he did it again it isn't the worst thing
in the world
it isn't child rape for instance but it
is an offense to which Robinson
understandably pled guilty more
important the trial that was coming to a
close last Friday is just one part of a
trial involving multiple other
defendants it's certainly possible that
Robinson's breaking the reporting
restrictions at the Leaves trial could
have prejudiced those trials to have
caused the collapse of such trial would
have been more than a blunder it would
have been an additional blow to victims
who deserve justice and then he talks
about Tommy Robinson you know fighting
the Islamic extremists in Great Britain
he concludes by saying Tommy Robinson
will be in prison for another year
all the people happy with the status quo
breathe a sigh of relief thank goodness
that troublemaker has gone away but the
real problem has not gone away there's
no chance of the real problem going away
because they have no plan for making it
go away so I just wanted to give a
little bit more context to who Tommy
Robinson is from somebody who I trust
Douglas Murray about this over at
National Review talking about what his
past is with the EDL and some of the
things that he has said and apologized
for and I hope that that corrects some
of the misconceptions that I put out
earlier this week ok so we will be back
here next week with all the latest
updates and all the latest news have
yourself a great weekend i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018